[Music]
listen to this new york post columnist
fox news contributor great friends of
the show carol markowitz a lifetime new
yorker is trading in the big apple for
the sunshine state in a fox news op-ed
carol opens up about her decision to
move her family writing quote i was a
new york supremacist and so it's with
some sadness and a lot of anger that i
feel our family now needs to leave the
city we've loved for so long we're going
to florida the state that's come to
regard the beacon of freedom in this
country carol joins us now carol
this is there's many reasons
but it's really about your kids
yep
yeah look there's so many things going
wrong in new york city right now but the
key thing for me is that we have put
kids last throughout the pandemic and we
continue to do that today
it's a city that really treats kids like
an afterthought and i have to get my
kids out of that i we can't stay you're
already seeing this you have three kids
in school and you're seeing them in
masks every day you feel you thought
this thing was going to end it doesn't
they don't seem to care european cities
countries they don't really have this
issue they know kids in mass is stupid
so now you're seeing a delay in your
kids development
yeah so my six-year-old has been in
masks you know his entire schooling
career so far he's in first grade he's
not reading yet i wrote about him this
week for the post my other two kids were
reading quite early they're very
voracious readers and i see a change and
i think it's because you know i i really
do see that it's because of the masking
he's a shy kid he doesn't repeat himself
he doesn't
you know
enunciate very well he doesn't
understand what his teacher is saying
it's a giant issue and the fact that we
ignore that this is going to be a
problem is is the problem to me it's
like the the pretense that in a year
we're not going to accept that these
masks caused actual problems for these
kids is ridiculous that's where we're
going to be in a year it's going to be
these articles about now it can be told
these masks are bad for kids yeah uh and
we know too there there's a reason why
you exhale uh it's to to expel and now
it's going back in your face 33 000 new
yorkers have moved to florida over the
last
uh 10 months you're now one of them
is was it hard finding housing
uh what was it like when you went down i
mean i hear real estate's through the
roof now
yeah i mean real estate is on fire there
we're heading in a few weeks so we
haven't we haven't quite left yet but we
have already secured our housing down
there and yeah it's extremely popular
and it makes sense because it's a place
where if you want your family to have
2019 normalcy ron desantis is there to
ensure that you do and you know i keep
saying like it's not about one
individual leader although he sets the
tone for the state but it's the
floridians have decided that they want
their normal lives they're not going to
stay suspended in this
masking theater they're not going to
stay suspended in this covid you know
restriction theater and they're going to
move on with their lives and ron
desantis is there to guide them through
it and we want to be a part of that and
think about what your governor just did
or the governor in new york just did
hearing about a variant in south africa
she immediately stopped elective
surgeries and called it an emergency
situation
again everyone's life grinds to a halt
in some way shape or form right you're
fired as a health care worker unless
you're double vaccinated as a cop soon
to be as a firefighter and and now
yesterday two days ago you hear about
this massive private industry get
vaccinated uh or be fined as a company
that's right and you know so you have
this governor and she you know i keep
referring to her as a geriatric governor
who's going around the state she is
never in a mask never yet my
six-year-old is in a mask from morning
until the end of the school day he gets
to take it off for 20 minutes for lunch
and that's it even outdoors during
recess which i know there are people
across the country listening to this
right now and thinking they still wear
masks outdoors but yes my kids have to
wear masks at school outdoors even today
december 2021 and our governor doesn't
you know so she has these these lofty
ideas but she doesn't live by any of
them absolutely uh carol a lot of people
are really struck by your column when a
new york post columnist says i'm leaving
new york and i'm going to still write
uh for the paper and your company
supports you you know how desperate
things are it's uh being a parent first
carol marquis thanks so much
thank you so much all right hi everyone
i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now